Traducteur: eric vautier
Relecteur: Elise LECAMP
Vous avez commencé votre journée,
vous êtes connecté à Internet,
vous avez regardé Facebook, Instagram,
peut-être une vidéo YouTube.
En fait, on a même commencé cet après-midi
avec une vidéo YouTube prise sur Internet,
et puis en fin de journée,
vous allez peut-être aller sur Wikipédia
pour en apprendre plus
sur quelque chose que vous aurez entendu
aujourd'hui et qui vous aura intéressé.
Juste pour être sûr que ça arrive,
je vais vous donner un petit fun fact :
René Goscinny, le scénariste d'Astérix,
est mort en fait d'un arrêt cardiaque
en faisant un test d'endurance
chez son cardiologue.
C'est ironique.
Mais il n'empêche que, pour quatre
milliards de personnes sur Terre,
cette routine de tous les jours que
vous avez, elle n'est pas possible.
Tout de suite, vous allez dire :
« Effectivement,
si on est au Sahara
ou au sommet d'une montagne,
on aura un problème de connectivité,
on n'aura pas de réseau, et tout ça. »
D'un côté, je vous dirais :
« Il n'y a pas vraiment quatre
milliards de personnes au Sahara,
et de nos jours, la majorité de la
population mondiale vit dans des villes. »
C'est plus un problème de coût et
d'infrastructures, que d'accès à Internet.
Par exemple à Cuba,
une heure de connexion dans un cybercafé
ou dans un parc coûtera un dollar.
Pour vous, pour moi,
ce n'est pas grand-chose,
à Cuba, c'est une journée de salaire.
Donc on peut se dire que
les Cubains, de fait,
ne sont pas ou [sont] mal connectés.
Un 2e phénomène auquel on ne pense pas
vraiment, qui est pourtant en croissance -
et c'est un problème -
c'est
le gouvernement qui décide pour votre bien
qu'il va censurer les réseaux.
C'est toujours pour votre bien.
La preuve :
l'an dernier en Éthiopie,
ils ont coupé en fait l'accès
à Internet pendant la durée
des examens d'entrée à l'université
pour éviter que les étudiants ne trichent.
Excellente raison.
Du coup, j'en profite
pour faire un petit aparté :
si aujourd'hui vous pouvez avoir tout
ce que vous devriez apprendre par cœur
au bout de votre main,
plus besoin d'apprendre par cœur.
Les enfants d'aujourd'hui
devront apprendre à réfléchir
quand on a juste appris à répéter.
Pensez-y quand vous moquerez de leurs
boutons : en fait, ils sont plus malins.
Et il y a une troisième raison
qui va vous toucher d'un peu plus près,
c'est une contrainte technologique.
C'est en fait deux lois ; l'une s'appelle
la loi de Moore et l'autre, de Nielsen.
La loi de Moore nous dit
que tous les 18 mois,
vous aurez un ordinateur deux fois
plus puissant pour le même prix.
Ça veut dire que si vous achetez
un téléphone portable aujourd'hui,
dans 18 mois, le modèle suivant arrivera,
C'est purement
la progression technologique.
De fait, les contenus, les images,
que vous allez générer avec ces téléphones
vont être aussi d'autant plus gros.
La loi de Nielsen parle des données qu'on
va transmettre, de la bande passante.
Elle nous dit que tous les 21 mois,
la bande passante va doubler.
Donc on pourra transmettre
deux fois plus de données
avec les mêmes fils,
les mêmes réseaux wifi.
C'est très bien jusqu'à
ce que vous disiez :
« D'un côté, 18 mois, ça double,
de l'autre, 21 mois, ça double. »
Donc forcément, il y a ces trois mois qui
constituent un goulot d'étranglement
et qui font qu' il y aura toujours
un problème de connectivité,
même dans les endroits
les mieux connectés.
Et comme n'importe quelle histoire,
elle devient vraiment réelle
quand elle est vraiment personnelle.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il y a plus de
personnel finalement qu'une maman ?
On a eu cette situation où
Maman est à la campagne -
imaginez la Lozère, un dimanche en hiver,
ce genre de connectivité -
et Maman a un fils qui est
programmeur-informaticien.
Il lui dit : « Il y a
un truc génial : Wikipédia.
C'est la réponse à toutes tes questions,
notamment sur Goscinny. »
Et puis il arrive, il commence
sa démonstration, ça ne marche pas.
Heureusement, il est programmeur,
informaticien, il se dit :
« On va chercher une solution. »
Internet ne vient pas à Maman, Maman ne
veut pas déménager et aller à Internet,
enlevons Internet de l'équation,
qu'est-ce qu'il reste ?
Il nous reste la solution :
c'est le contenu.
Donc il écrit un programme
qui s'appelle Kiwix,
Wikipédia, wiki, kiwi,
et un X, ça, c'est cool.
(Rires)
Et Kiwix va télécharger ce contenu depuis
un lieu où vous avez une bonne connexion,
il va le mettre dans un petit fichier
qui contiendra tout ce que vous voulez,
un site de contenus, comme
Wikipédia par exemple,
pour ensuite
le promener avec vous, l'emmener sur
une clé USB ou sur votre téléphone.
Maintenant les puces de stockage
ne sont vraiment pas chères,
et comme ça, vous allez pouvoir montrer
à Maman les merveilles de ce monde.
Comme il est généreux, il dit :
« Je vais le mettre sur Internet
puisque d'autres ont une maman,
qui a un problème de connectivité,
pourront en profiter,
faire pareil que moi. »
Aujourd'hui, on a trois
millions d'utilisateurs.
Ils étaient un million
et demi l'an dernier,
on en attend 4 à 5 millions l'an prochain.
Si vous comptez l'électricité,
les serveurs, les frais,
ça revient à peu près à un centime par
personne, autant dire que c'est gratuit.
On a eu des utilisations qu'on attendait,
sur lesquelles on avait travaillé.
La Fondation Orange par exemple,
l'opérateur téléphonique,
monte ce qu'ils appellent
des écoles numériques en Afrique.
Ils arrivent dans un village
sans téléphone ni électricité,
ils construisent avec des matériaux
locaux, ils embauchent un instituteur,
ils amènent des panneaux solaires,
un serveur qui crée un petit réseau local.
Et en fait, en 2018, sachez-le,
il est moins cher d'offrir à ces enfants
une petite tablette à 30 dollars
fabriquée en Chine,
que d'acheter un livre pour chaque
matière et pour chaque enfant.
Le calcul économique est là :
on est à une période de notre vie,
de l'humanité
où c'est moins cher finalement
d'avoir de la haute technologie.
Autre exemple à côté de nous :
en Suisse, en Allemagne, aux États-Unis,
la formation pour les prisonniers
qui font des longues peines.
C'est bien de les mettre en prison, mais
c'est mieux s'ils évitent d'y revenir.
Donc on leur apprend un métier,
mais en prison, pas de connectivité.
A nouveau, on utilise Kiwix
et les méthodes hors ligne
pour leur donner une chance de redémarrer.
Mais aussi les utilisations
qu'on n'avait pas prévues.
Si vous connaissez la Corée,
pays formidable où on fait les JO au Sud
et où on est puni pour les
avoir regardés au Nord.
(Rires)
Il y a des dissidents nord-coréens qui ont
fui leur pays, qui se retrouvent au sud,
et qui décident d'y retourner.
Ils n'y retournent pas les mains vides,
ils y retournent avec des clés USB sur
lesquelles on a mis Wikipedia en coréen,
des séries télé du genre Friends,
des soap operas, n'importe quoi,
finalement la culture locale.
La frontière entre la Chine
et la Corée du Nord est une rivière,
il leur suffit de nager, puis ils
« perdent » leurs clés USB dans la rue.
Pourquoi ? Parce que le pays
n'est pas si pauvre que ça,
il y a une élite
qui dispose d'ordinateurs.
Ils ne tournent pas sur Windows
mais sur quelque chose qui s'appelle
« Étoile rouge », étonnamment.
Mais qui peut lire Kiwix.
Ces gens sont curieux.
Trouver une clé USB dans la rue
n'est pas banal,
Ils vont regarder ce qu'il y a dessus,
puis vont s'apercevoir
que le monde que le gouvernement
leur décrit, ce n'est pas le vrai monde.
C'est la meilleure propagande au final,
c'est celle qui est vraie.
Et ça marche plutôt bien : ils ont
distribué environ 60 000 clés par an.
Depuis, ils ont même acheté
un drone qui fait les livraisons
à quelqu'un qui récupère de l'autre côté.
Si vous vous souvenez
du tournant du siècle,
on nous disait :
« L'Homme sera sur Mars en 2020. »
Bon.
(Rires)
On n'est pas pressé
et le monde ne s'est pas arrêté
de tourner pour autant.
Et c'est pareil pour Internet.
On vous dit : « Vous avez Internet ou
non ; vous avez la 4G et la 5G ou non.
Si non, vous avez perdu. » Non !
Le monde n'est pas
des perdants et des gagnants.
Au final, ce que vous voulez
n'est pas l'outil,
c'est l'usage que
cet outil vous apportera.
Vous voulez cette connaissance.
Et maintenant, on peut tous l'avoir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)